[Music]
uh let's look
at1 so he's doing
K and he's trying to hit me
here now I got to clear the line of
attack so I'm here and I lined up on his
Center so where I moved into was the
zone of s
and the zone of sanctuary is
identifiable if you use a
circle inside a square you shade in the
circle the corners of the square are
unshaded so those are your diagonals 10
2 4 and 8 okay and what that's going to
do is if I
move perfectly North
I am back in the radius of that Circle
and getting hit if I move at the angle
you see that I start to move outside the
radius I'm in the corner of the square
at 4:00 okay so you want to move to
four and you're now lined up on his
Center okay so this is the m you guys
can move those lights for you here too
we can keep going all right and my
target
is the hands
okay and my power hand is my right hand
and it has to stay on the wui line okay
and then I have to allow that two to
three in there for my margin for error
if I miss so in other words if I move
way
outside and I put my power Hound where
it goes goes I missed the
target if I get
here I touch the Target but I I have
very little margin for error as we're
going on so I always have to give that 2
to three Ines past the Target and this
works okay and then we reverse engineer
everything so he'll
rewind and we
know that my Joe can't go outside my
outer rim so it stays
here so as he's
going I'm going to be late here but
embryonically he stops
here then I hit my
target okay but let's look at the
embryonic because this this often messes
up ieto
people this is a
block and there's no blocking in Ikea
and this this is still a block okay and
that's a pipe
tra the the non-c
contestation is to rotate here not to
rotate your weapon against the Y aspect
that's not non-c contestation okay so
this is a
block let's just look at it as a block
but first note this is not
iido okay okay so he's trying to hit the
head
I come here and be
onor if I bring my hands
closer to his
weapon you see my hands are now
vulnerable to the strike okay so I can't
do that all right so let's trade rolls
are you are your muscle bellies killing
you all right here we
go get in there okay so we he he's there
okay and now the reason I'm making this
point is here's his head level that's
where I'm hitting hold the weapon okay
no no no got it you separate your hands
to the third J okay there I am don't let
me move
it if he comes near the near the
pressure bring your hand up to to it
then he can hold it he can hold it do
you see but when he goes to to not risk
his hand then he can't he can't hold
that Weapon It's just leverage okay and
so for example the more I am at the
distal end the more leverage I'll have
the easier that is um this is enough
leverage his head height that's enough
leverage for him to not have enough
mechanical advantage so as block goes
it's not a good block okay so you don't
want to do
that
um why did I bring that up
because when you go
here people think that this hits like a
j do you
see they go They're going like a curve
there you see that and you don't want
that
curve this goes straight down boom
straight
down straight down after it hits this
part comes
up not not my tip making that Circle do
you see that okay so if we
[Music]
come onto
this this this I don't
know and I do a
j it's a kind of skimming day as opposed
to is what I want okay that's what I
want so I wanted to go down and then
this comes up not this not that okay
and that is going to take take you to
the application Phase so go go slow so
you can see so is where I hit those
hands I don't block this okay so if you
watch the path of the weapon it's going
no just let me show the path it's going
boom
hitting
whipping so watch that the two ends are
not they're not in relationship they're
in anti- relationship so I go
up hit so if he just sticks his Joe out
as a
Target I don't go
here I whip
it is what I'm doing okay so I won't do
it on him but this actually just and he
hits the hands there boom hits back in
comes up and in I go okay so that is
what I'm doing here
so even if I do it
embryonically I don't want
to skim
it I want it to go straight down boom
but I don't want the two hands to be in
relationship with each other they kind
of
Wiggle it's like a
whip in okay let's try that so he goes B
pop in it's the basics embryonic you
guys see how I bringing it up it's in
that cuz that's going to be the whip
boom is where I'm going to hit okay so
watch I'm bringing it up I just stop
here okay and now his weapon is a
training line it's not a Joe anymore
okay and I keep the relationship going
to parallel to the deck lift the back
end up
and in I
go boom pop back end up and I
go
different and not
powerful boom boom
in
up boom in it's this back end that
paints what everyone wants to paint with
the front end okay don't do that all
right
let's something for the rest of you and
and people here
too this arm is a is a problem and
usually because people are making a big
deal out of the embryonic phase and
thinking it's a block and that you can
block these Joe you can't block the jum
okay so they want to uh
they want to
have like power here do you see that and
they get really weird
about my is my elbow out you
see they get weird grips don't put your
elbow out do you understand the this is
Niko you're giving Niko to yourself in a
way it's right here okay so hold their
Joe is very natural okay
and uh because I want my body to to whip
in here
okay the
hand is going to be natural grip you see
just like you're holding the pistol left
hand you natural grip not like this not
like that natural grip okay and because
I rotated up the circle into the zon
Sanctuary my arm is is technically on
the other side of my Joe from his point
of
view I don't know what camera angle you
need Sean to get that it's not over
here it's on this side everything is on
this side of my Joe so I don't have to
make it all weird to be on that side
okay does that make sense so I hold it
naturally just naturally I move I whip
it boom pick up the back end and in I go
okay so nothing weird with your elbow
and your grip all right let's try it so
let's go back to what a training line is
he comes around okay what I mean is this
is the line that I go straight
down my weapon strike goes straight down
I am not fighting the Joe right now so I
don't want to non-contest the Joe it's
not a Joe I'm not blocking it okay
so I don't need to rotate the cross in
order to come around to go
up right from here my weapon just
follows the weapon down I don't start
turning it you see I'm on the top I'm on
the diagonal top and as you go further
I'm more on top more on top okay so I
just go straight down don't move his
weapon boom straight down then the hands
displace the weapon
p in again one straight down follow the
weapon straight down keep the
relationship you have right now straight
down
boom up in incorrect I start I'm
starting to make my way on top on top
would be totally this so I start on the
side and like let's say that's 3:00
12:00 on top of the Joe and I start
moving towards 2 do you see 1:00 12:30
and now I'm here at 12:30 when I hit
that no straight down
boom in okay try it again if if you
go if you're here and you're not going
straight down look how I'm going
straight down I'm just going straight to
his hands I'm just letting the weapon
fall that's all I'm doing there's no
doing that okay so I stay at three I
start at three and I try to go down
three that means my weapon's in the
vertical
plane if I move towards two on his Joe
or all the way to
12:30 as you're
descending that's that J that's that J
thing you get
here instead of just coming straight
down
straight
down what you want okay you don't want
to hit look how I'm going to do that J
the Joe's going that way and then it
glances off you don't want that okay all
right um
jumi so this is for
shman or anything overhead
okay
and the Sensei taught a different
depending on where you
were and um when you joined him okay so
when I first started with other of his
students this is he did it like this
stay on the line come here you see and
then he'd come off the line and
sometimes he'd go like
this because he was acrobatic weird okay
or sometimes he'd violate the rule of
One Two To None okay
but later he he'd move one so as he does
his one step I did my one step and then
I tapped here okay so careful if you're
watching
videos cuz you're going to see the he
does this he stayed on the line that
doesn't make sense stay on the line what
happens if my Joe breaks that doesn't
make sense that's a contestation and
this isn't going to stop it okay so
you're going to do if you watch what
ronan's doing in the video he's doing
what I taught him which is one two okay
that's the first thing don't stay on the
line it
is one two then we got to deal with the
block
okay and you don't want to
block it is an embrionic thing so he
goes here and now I have another
guideline
and that's what I
use to follow straight
down okay that means go back and let's
say he's doing showman the real
technique is right there okay without
the
block so let's look at
Power because most
people emphasize the block
with this big thing between your hands
okay but
now you won't have as much power as you
think okay I know it feels weird cuz
that looks like it's power but off of
his
Joe when I'm here like this it's very
hard to control that you can see how it
wiggled on me even at that pace okay you
got to choke up on the weapon you have
to choke up on the weapon and you hit
here GL you hit there okay
so watch How I do
that you're at third Joe and in the
technique don't go all the way to there
in the technique here short boom hit
right there now you're back at third jaw
on the other side okay so if you
go uh boom you're here oh I don't know
what you're going to do you see that so
you follow the third Joe
Rule and you look for this kind of short
stick not long stick yeah under this
ideal conditions you could do that but
you're going to pull to the new third
Joe and is where you your hip at and
it's just smacking B down okay not this
kind of Wiggly thing okay all right
we're going to play with that short joke
hitting the bag
try so on all the atos you have a rule
you can't expose the spine of your
weapon because the weapon like all
weapons they have to be between you and
the person so when you point it down
it's not ready it's not in the fight
it's vulnerable okay it would be like a
gunfight and the threat is already here
and I'm going to point my weapon at the
ground just no that's a no no okay um
weapon has to be between you and the
opponent so let's do the first
onei and I'm here you don't want to ever
hit so hard and so unrelated with the
power hand being the right hand that the
Joe is pointed down because now the
spine is vulnerable to him he can't he
can just push it down come in and then
that's it I'm done the weapon's gone
okay you never do that so on this
technique when I'm going to
when I'm going around when you come back
here like this it's very hard to keep
that that tip up and so you'll see a lot
of people when they're doing it it's
like it's pointed down at the end and no
okay that on top of the fact that now
you're not at third Joe you got to do
something weird to come back okay so
it's out oh it's where you're hitting
here you're at third Joe and you're good
to go okay
um when you do it he didn't really take
the C me I didn't want to break his
hands but it goes to parallel to the
deck is what you want to do parallel to
the deck
okay all right try Okay so again I I
know it looks like you get this big
whack there okay uh but the problem is
that here's where you first hit the
hands
right and that's where it completes okay
so it has to pass through those hands to
get here and what ends up happening go
ahead do what you did he went too
far yeah okay and now he goes to the
strike and now this is the same problem
with the block this is the dislin you
see and it doesn't
have the mechanical advantage you think
it does because it's too far away from
the fulcrum but when he moves
closer do you see goinging it up he gets
more control now he starts to put his
weight into it and he has a lot more
control go
back push a weight into it and the
handle's going to go the grip's going to
go down without this okay so that's why
you got to choke up on on the weapon
okay from being able to control the tip
and not exposing the spine